Adriana was talking to a homeless guy near her neighborhood in Chicago. And at some point, they started talking about, you know, his life on the street, why he was out there begging for money.
Adriana在芝加哥她家附近和一名无家可归的男子交谈。在谈话的某个时刻，他们聊到了他的街头生活，以及他为什么流落街头乞讨。
He straight up told me, I do it to pay for my heroin addiction.
他直截了当地告诉我，我是为了支付海洛因毒瘾的费用才这么做的。
Which, you know, not the typical answer. And then he tells her this story. He's from Puerto Rico, and he was flown to Chicago for rehab years ago. But then after three days, he quit rehab. And since then, he's been living on the streets. It's been five years.
这并不是一个常见的回答。然后他向她讲述了他的故事。他来自波多黎各，多年前被送到芝加哥进行戒毒治疗。但三天后，他放弃了治疗。从那时起，他就一直流落街头。已经五年了。
Now, Adriana is the editor of a newspaper-- a bilingual newspaper called The Gate that comes out in a mostly Mexican neighborhood called Back of the Yards. And in her interviews, just going around the neighborhood, talking to people about what's going on, people started mentioning there are all these Puerto Rican drug addicts who come to the neighborhood for treatment, quit treatment, and then just stay, homeless. And then she realized, oh, wait a second. She knew these guys. She'd been seeing some of them for years selling lotions and socks on the sidewalk.
现在，Adriana是一家报纸的编辑，一份名为《大门》（The Gate）的双语报纸，在芝加哥一个主要是墨西哥裔的社区“Back of the Yards”发行。在她的采访中，当她在社区里走动，和人们谈论正在发生的事情时，人们开始提到有许多波多黎各瘾君子来到社区接受治疗，放弃治疗，然后就留了下来，无家可归。然后她意识到，等等。她认识这些人。她多年来一直看到他们中的一些人在人行道上兜售乳液和袜子。
Yeah they were walking back and forth on 47th Street all the time. And so I just started stopping people on the street.
是的，他们总是来回走在47街上。所以我开始在街上拦住人。
Any street person with a Puerto Rican accent. And she heard the same weird story over and over. They were flown here from Puerto Rico for rehab. They quit rehab and ended up on the street. She writes and edits so much about the neighborhood, but this was happening right under her nose all this time?
任何带有波多黎各口音的流浪者。她一遍又一遍地听到同样奇怪的故事。他们是被从波多黎各飞到这里进行戒毒治疗的。他们放弃了治疗，最终流落街头。她写了并编辑了这么多关于这个社区的文章，但这件事一直就在她眼皮底下发生？
And in a period of about four months I talked to at least 23 people, just kind of like approaching people on the street.
在大约四个月的时间里，我谈了至少23个人，只是在街上接触他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Wait. So are you just running down the street here?
等等。所以你是在街上奔跑吗？
Yeah, I was running after these two guys I saw on Ashland and 48th, hoping that they were Puerto Rican. And their names were Hector and Jonathan. And they were telling me that they came from Puerto Rico. They were told that they were going to find a great place here in Chicago with medicine, with treatment, doctors, even a pool. And when they got here, there was no detox. There was no medicine or anything. This is Hector.
是的，我当时正在追赶我在Ashland和48街看到的两个家伙，希望他们是波多黎各人。他们的名字叫Hector和Jonathan。他们告诉我，他们来自波多黎各。他们被告知，他们将在芝加哥找到一个很棒的地方，有药物、有治疗、有医生，甚至还有一个游泳池。当他们到达这里时，根本没有排毒。没有药物，什么都没有。这是Hector。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And then this guy, Jonathan, he said that the municipal government in Puerto Rico had bought a one-way ticket for him to come to Chicago.
然后这个叫Jonathan的家伙说，波多黎各的市政府为他买了一张来芝加哥的单程票。
Wait. The government itself?
等等。政府本身？
Yeah, the municipal government in Puerto Rico.
是的，波多黎各的市政府。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
What?
什么？
And here in Chicago--
在芝加哥这里——
Wait, wait, wait. Basically, they're saying like, you need treatment, but we're not going to give it. We're just going to send you to Chicago.
等等，等等。基本上，他们是在说，你需要治疗，但我们不会提供。我们只是要把你送到芝加哥。
Yeah. I mean, I was shocked. I couldn't believe it. So I asked him again.
是的。我是说，我当时很震惊。我简直不敢相信。所以我又问了他一遍。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Did the municipality pay for your ticket?
市政府为你支付了机票吗？
Si. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
是的。[西班牙语]
So the details of the story that Adriana kept hearing from these Puerto Rican drug users were crazy. Several guys told her that it was the police who drove them to the airport in Puerto Rico. It was the police who helped arrange for their one-way tickets.
所以Adriana从这些波多黎各吸毒者那里听到的故事细节非常疯狂。几个人告诉她，是警察开车送他们去波多黎各的机场。是警察帮助他们安排了单程机票。
Not just one, but lots of guys were told that there would be a swimming pool, that the facilities in the United States were going to be clean and beautiful with doctors and nurses. And then when they arrived in Chicago, they were taken to these places-- and there were a bunch of them-- that were basically just, like, flop houses, open 24 hours a day with group therapy going till late at night, sometimes 10 or 13 hours straight.
不仅是一个，很多人都被告知会有游泳池，美国的设施会非常干净漂亮，有医生和护士。当他们到达芝加哥时，他们被带到这些地方——有很多这样的地方——基本上就是些廉价旅馆，24小时开放，群体治疗一直持续到深夜，有时连续10或13个小时。
The therapy was really just basically, like, AA meetings led by former addicts who did very un-AA things, like yell at them and berate them. When the guys would go through detox, because there was no medicine or methadone or professional staff, they were sometimes given folk remedies, like an onion to bite on, or alcohol would be poured in their belly buttons. And after a while, they'd leave without much cash, no way to get home.
治疗实际上基本上就是由前瘾君子领导的匿名戒酒会（AA），他们做的事情一点也不像AA，比如对他们大喊大叫，责骂他们。当这些人进行排毒时，因为没有药物、美沙酮或专业人员，他们有时会得到一些民间疗法，比如咬洋葱，或者把酒精倒在肚脐上。过了一段时间，他们离开时身上没什么钱，也无法回家。
When I was talking to Hector and Jonathan, they were saying, our families have no money. They can't afford a plane ticket. And sometimes, actually, from other people I heard that their families sometimes don't believe them, either. They really don't believe them, or they don't believe them anymore. I mean, we're talking about people that have addiction problems.
当我和Hector与Jonathan交谈时，他们说，我们的家庭没有钱。他们买不起机票。而且有时候，实际上从其他人那里我听说，他们的家人有时也不相信他们。他们真的不相信他们，或者他们不再相信他们了。我是说，我们谈论的是有毒瘾问题的人。
So basically, they're stranded in Chicago. They don't speak English. They're in this place they've never been before. They're drug addicts. And then also they're from a tropical island and they're in the middle of winter in Chicago.
所以基本上，他们被困在芝加哥。他们不会说英语。他们在一个他们从未去过的地方。他们是瘾君子。而且他们来自热带岛屿，却在芝加哥的寒冬中。
Yeah. And that's something that also some of them told me. Like, they don't have the proper clothing. They don't know how to survive the winter.
是的。这也是他们中的一些人告诉我的。比如，他们没有合适的衣服。他们不知道如何在大冬天生存。
Adriana got curious about the rehab places that these men were talking about. She'd never noticed them before, but now she started seeing them everywhere, all over the city. Just asking people and driving around, she found 14. But when she searched city and state records and did Freedom of Information requests to see if these places got city funding or were registered or licensed in any way, just if there was any information on them at all, there's nothing. They were totally off the grid.
Adriana对这些人提到的戒毒所产生了好奇。她以前从未注意过它们，但现在她开始在城市各处看到它们。只是通过询问人们和开车到处转，她发现了14个。但当她搜索城市和州的记录并发出信息自由请求，以查看这些地方是否获得城市资助或以任何方式注册或许可，仅仅是查看是否有任何关于它们的信息时，什么都没有。它们完全处于监控之外。
The authorities have no idea that they are there. I talked to several city agencies with the Department of Buildings, the Department of Public Health, the Department of Support Services. And I mean, they just didn't even know what I was talking-- they didn't even want to comment because they had no idea that this was going on.
当局根本不知道它们在那里。我和几个城市机构交谈过，包括建筑部、公共卫生部、支持服务部。我是说，他们甚至不知道我在说什么——他们甚至不想发表评论，因为他们根本不知道发生了什么事。
In Illinois, treatment services for drug addiction have to be licensed by a state agency, especially if they're residential-- if people are living there. Adriana told the agency what she was finding.
在伊利诺伊州，药物成瘾的治疗服务必须由州机构许可，特别是如果它们是居住型的——如果人们住在那里的话。Adriana告诉了该机构她的发现。
They said, we do not know what you're talking about. We don't know about these treatment houses.
他们说，我们不知道你在说什么。我们不知道这些治疗所。
We don't know about people being flown here from Puerto Rico?
我们不知道有人从波多黎各被飞到这里？
They didn't know that, either.
他们也不知道这一点。
If the men Adriana was talking to on the street were telling the truth, this was very strange. It meant that government officials in Puerto Rico were sending addicts to Chicago for treatment, but the places they were sending them to cannot offer treatment under Illinois law because they're not licensed for it. Why would they be doing that? Did they know the places were unlicensed? Was somebody getting rich off this, there or here? Was it some kind of scam?
如果Adriana在街上交谈的那些人说的是真的，这非常奇怪。这意味着波多黎各的政府官员正在将瘾君子送到芝加哥接受治疗，但他们送去的地方根据伊利诺伊州法律不能提供治疗，因为它们没有获得许可。他们为什么要这样做？他们知道这些地方没有执照吗？有人在从中发财吗，是在那里还是在这里？这是某种骗局吗？
For example, is anybody getting their IDs and selling them in the black market? That's one thing that a lot of guys kept telling me. They ask us to turn in our IDs. And when we walked out, they didn't give it back to us. Is anybody making money out of this?
例如，有没有人拿走他们的身份证并在黑市上出售？这是许多人一直告诉我的事情。他们要求我们交出身份证。当我们走出来时，他们没有把身份证还给我们。有人从中赚钱吗？
She talked to a case manager who works with injection drug users in Chicago. And then he went around and did his own informal survey and found 93 guys like this-- guys who were flown in from Puerto Rico with promises of rehab, who skipped rehab. Adriana also found a researcher in Puerto Rico name Rafael Torruella, who wrote a dissertation about drug users being flown off the island to unlicensed facilities. He told her it's not just happening in Chicago.
她和一位在芝加哥与注射吸毒者工作的个案经理交谈。然后他四处走动并进行了自己的非正式调查，发现了93个这样的人——被从波多黎各飞来并承诺提供康复治疗，却放弃康复的家伙。Adriana还在波多黎各找到了一位名叫Rafael Torruella的研究员，他写了一篇关于吸毒者被飞离岛屿到未经许可的设施的论文。他告诉她，这不仅仅发生在芝加哥。
Different municipalities ship, send, relocate, however we want to call it, drug users from Puerto Rico to different sides of the United States. We know that from Fajardo, they would send to Philadelphia. We know that from Barceloneta, Vega Baja, y Vega Alta, Dorado, they would send to New York City. But there's also New Jersey. There's Florida. There's South Carolina, Wisconsin, Boston. The more you ask, the more you see that this has been happening for a long time.
不同的市政当局将吸毒者从波多黎各运送、发送、迁移到美国的不同地方，随你怎么称呼。我们知道从Fajardo，他们会把人送到费城。我们知道从Barceloneta、Vega Baja、Vega Alta、Dorado，他们会把人送到纽约市。但还有新泽西州、佛罗里达州、南卡罗来纳州、威斯康星州、波士顿。你问得越多，你就越能看到这种情况已经发生很长时间了。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Not It!" Stories where people are facing something difficult and they declare, no. Someone else can handle it. Let's just send this one elsewhere. This is not my problem, not right now.
这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是Ira Glass。今天在我们的节目中，“不是我！”（Not It!）在这个节目中，人们面临困难的事情，并宣布，不。别人可以处理它。让我们把这个扔给别处吧。这不是我的问题，不是现在。
We have three stories for you including, later in the show, a group of high school students dealing with the collateral damage from a joke-- yes, a joke, and not a joke that any of them told. It was a joke told on television 15 years before. Stay with us.
我们有三个故事要讲，包括在节目后面，一群高中生处理一个笑话带来的附带损害——是的，一个笑话，而且不是他们中任何人讲的笑话。那是一个15年前在电视上讲的笑话。请留下来。
We are continuing right now in Act One of our show. Act One, "Como Se Dice, 'Not It'?"
我们现在继续节目的第一幕。第一幕，“Como Se Dice, 'Not It'?”（怎么说“不是我”？）
So most of the Puerto Rican addicts that Adriana Cordona-Maguigad met on the street have been sent to a treatment center called Segunda Vida, Second Life. She decided she had to visit and see it for herself. She had the address, 50th and Ashland. But when she went by, she couldn't see a sign or anything.
所以Adriana Cordona-Maguigad在街上遇到的大多数波多黎各瘾君子都被送到了一个名为Segunda Vida（第二次生命）的康复中心。她决定她必须亲自去看看。她有地址，50街和Ashland。但当她经过时，她看不到标志或任何东西。
All I saw was a little corner store, a cell phone shop, a parking lot, and then a gray brick building, until someone told me, just go, look up to the second floor. You'll see in the window-- in the top window, you'll see a sign. And I saw the sign. It is super small.
我只看到一个小角落商店、一家手机店、一个停车场，然后是一栋灰色的砖房，直到有人告诉我，去，抬头看二楼。你会看到窗户里——在顶部的窗户里，你会看到一个标志。我看到了标志。它超级小。
There's a little green logo with two As for Alcoholics Anonymous. Adriana called AA, and they said they had nothing to do with this place. And in fact, they don't run any kind of residential treatment facilities at all. So she tried to get inside.
有一个绿色的小标志，上面有两个A代表匿名戒酒会（AA）。Adriana给AA打电话，他们说他们与这个地方无关。事实上，他们根本不经营任何形式的居住型治疗设施。所以她试图进去。
At Segunda Vida, they wouldn't let me go past the top of the staircase. I called. I went back in person many times. And each time I went, I asked to speak with the person in charge, but they would always tell me to go back on a different day.
在Segunda Vida，他们不允许我越过楼梯顶端。我打过电话。我多次亲自去过。每次去，我都要求和负责人谈谈，但他们总是告诉我改天再来。
Could you see inside?
你能看到里面吗？
Yeah. At the top of the staircase, you find kind of like an open room. And there is a painting on the wall that says, Segunda Vida. And I saw just men walking back and forth, sipping coffee and smoking cigarettes. And actually, I went to another group. I went to El Grito Desesperado, The Desperate Scream. And they have the phone number--
能。在楼梯顶端，你会发现一个类似开放的房间。墙上有一幅画，上面写着Segunda Vida。我看到男人们在走来走去，喝咖啡和抽烟。实际上，我去过另一个小组。我去过El Grito Desesperado（绝望的尖叫）。他们有电话号码——
Wait, wait, wait. They called their rehab group The Desperate Scream?
等等，等等。他们把他们的康复小组叫做“绝望的尖叫”？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I was shocked, as well.
是的。是的。是的，我也很震惊。
It's like the name of a horror film or something.
这就像一部恐怖电影的名字之类的。
Yeah.
是的。
Desperate Scream. And now coming out, Desperate Scream 2 .
“绝望的尖叫”。现在要出续集了，“绝望的尖叫2”。
There is a Desperate Scream 2. It's actually further east.
确实有“绝望的尖叫2”。它实际上在更东边。
Wait. No way. Really?
等等。不会吧。真的？
So I went to El Grito Desesperado, The Desperate Scream, on a Saturday evening. And the cigarette smoke was overwhelming. And it was really dirty. It was, like, dusty. And someone was giving testimony really loud. And some people were kind of not paying attention. They were talking. People kept coming back and forth to buy cigarettes in, like, a small little counter in the back. It seemed very unorganized.
所以我周六晚上去了El Grito Desesperado，“绝望的尖叫”。烟味浓得让人无法呼吸。而且真的很脏。就像到处是灰尘。有人在大声作证。有些人根本没注意听。他们在交谈。人们不停地进进出出，在后面一个小的柜台买香烟。这看起来很不组织。
Somebody gave a very personal testimony. A man who looked like he just came from the shower walked through the room, she says. His hair was wet. He had a towel over his shoulder. Another man was asleep in a cot on the side. There was a lot of cursing in the testimony, which surprised her, a lot of crude language, and berating themselves. Like she'd been told, it was not a normal AA meeting.
有人做了一个非常私人的见证。她说，一个看起来刚洗完澡的男人走过房间。他的头发还是湿的。他的肩上搭着一条毛巾。另一个男人在旁边的小床上睡着了。见证中有很多咒骂，这让她很惊讶，很多粗俗的语言，还有自责。正如她被告知的那样，这不是一个正常的AA会议。
When I was looking into these places, I was still meeting new people on the street. And one day I met this man, Manuel.
当我在调查这些地方时，我还在街上遇到新的人。有一天我遇到了这个人，Manuel。
Manuel is not his real name. He asked Adriana that she not use his real name here on the radio.
Manuel不是他的真名。他要求Adriana不要在广播中使用他的真名。
He was squatting by the door of a local supermarket looking up. And he was asking customers for spare change. And when I asked him, like, how long have you been here, he'd just arrived from Puerto Rico two weeks ago.
他蹲在当地一家超市的门口抬头看。他正在向顾客要零钱。当我问他，你在这里待了多久时，他两周前刚从波多黎各到达。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He seemed totally shocked and lost. The other men I've talked to, they've been here for months and years. But with Manuel, he was just starting out. He had no idea of what to do or where to go.
他看起来完全震惊和迷茫。我交谈过的其他男人，他们在这里待了几个月甚至几年。但Manuel，他才刚刚开始。他根本不知道该做什么或去哪里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So Manuel told me that he also came to Segunda Vida, but he walked out after a few days, and he really wants to go back to the island. But the problem is that the people at Segunda Vida kept his documents. So I told him, I'll go with him to get them.
所以Manuel告诉我，他也去了Segunda Vida，但几天后就走出来了，他真的很想回岛上。但问题是，Segunda Vida的人扣留了他的文件。所以我告诉他，我陪你去拿回它们。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
[WHISTLING]
[吹口哨声]
Where are you guys?
你们在哪里？
So basically, we're right outside of Segunda Vida. This is last summer. So after knocking on the door several times, Manuel starts walking up the stairway saying that he left some documents there and that he's been talking to someone who keeps telling him, go back on a different day and then a different day.
所以基本上，我们就在Segunda Vida外面。这是去年夏天。在敲了几次门之后，Manuel开始走上楼梯，说他把一些文件留在了那里，他一直在和一个人说话，那个人一直告诉他，改天再来，然后又改天。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
But he really needs his documents.
但他真的需要他的文件。
So who's with you on this trip?
这次行程谁陪你？
Well, I asked a couple of colleagues. One of them is a big, tall guy, just in case. I was coming in with my equipment to confront these people.
嗯，我叫了几个同事。其中一个是又高又大的家伙，以防万一。我带着我的设备进来去质问这些人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
There is a man from Segunda Vida, and he sees me coming in with a microphone. He immediately calls someone for help and says, someone is recording.
有一个Segunda Vida的人，他看到我带着麦克风进来。他立即打电话找人帮忙，并说，有人在录音。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Yeah, what's going on, guys?
是的，怎么回事，伙计们？
So Manuel keeps saying, I need my documents, but they keep telling us that we need to wait outside.
所以Manuel一直在说，我需要我的文件，但他们一直告诉我们我们需要在外面等。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I keep telling them that I want to talk to the head of the program.
我一直告诉他们，我想和项目负责人谈谈。
I need to speak with someone in charge.
我需要和负责人谈谈。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I need to speak with someone about the program.
我需要和某人谈谈这个项目。
But again, they keep telling me to leave, to wait outside, that there is no one here, that there is no head of the program.
但他们又一直叫我离开，在外面等，说这里没有人，没有项目负责人。
But I need to speak with someone-- the person in charge of this program.
但我需要和某人谈谈——这个项目的负责人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Why not?
为什么不行？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I felt like, no. You cannot just be telling me that no one is in charge when you just had these men here who just walked out. You're keeping his documents. I just felt like they were not making sense. I felt like everyone's giving me the run-around, like no one is responsible for anything.
我感觉，不行。你不能在明明刚让这些男人走出来的情况下，告诉我没人负责。你在扣留他的文件。我只是觉得他们说的没道理。我感觉每个人都在敷衍我，好像没人对任何事情负责。
We'll be waiting outside for his documents.
我们会在外面等他的文件。
Yeah, so we all agreed to wait outside, but I ended up staying in. That's when someone kind of came, pushed through the crowd, and came with a white envelope and gave Manuel his documents.
是的，所以我们都同意在外面等，但我最后还是留在了里面。就在那时，有人穿过人群，带着一个白色的信封过来，把文件给了Manuel。
No, make sure those are your documents. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不，确定那是你的文件。[西班牙语]
So I looked through the envelope and I found Manuel's birth certificate, his ID, and his medical records, where I also found that he was HIV positive.
所以我查看了信封，发现了Manuel的出生证明、身份证和医疗记录，我还发现他艾滋病毒呈阳性。
Which he knew, right?
他知道，对吧？
Oh, yeah. Yeah, he knew. But I was just really upset. Like, why would you send someone who has medical needs away from where he can find services? I mean, we're talking about someone who needs medicine, who needs treatment.
哦，是的。是的，他知道。但我真的很生气。我是说，你为什么要让一个有医疗需求的人离开他可以找到服务的地方？我是说，我们谈论的是一个需要药物、需要治疗的人。
Back in Puerto Rico, he was getting medicine to manage his HIV. Here in the States, at Segunda Vida, they weren't providing that. A week after forcing her way up the stairs to Segunda Vida, Adriana was surprised to get a call from a guy who said he was one of the founders of Segunda Vida. His name's Efren Moreno, and he agreed to come to her office for an interview.
在波多黎各，他有药来控制他的艾滋病。在美国这里，在Segunda Vida，他们没有提供。强行上楼到Segunda Vida一周后，Adriana惊讶地接到了一个自称是Segunda Vida创始人之一的家伙的电话。他的名字是Efren Moreno，他同意来到她的办公室接受采访。
He showed up in jeans and T-shirt with one of the guys who had actually tried to kick Adriana out of Segunda Vida the week before. They wouldn't let Adriana record, but she took notes. Efren Moreno told her that he is a former addict. In fact, he'd gone to a group in Milwaukee like Segunda Vida that was open 24 hours called El Ultimo Paso, The Last Step. Then he moved to Chicago and he started to Segunda Vida.
他穿着牛仔裤和T恤，带着上周试图把Adriana赶出Segunda Vida的其中一个人一起出现了。他们不允许Adriana录音，但她做了笔记。Efren Moreno告诉她，他是一名戒掉的瘾君子。事实上，他曾去过密尔沃基一个像Segunda Vida那样24小时开放的小组，叫El Ultimo Paso（最后一步）。后来他搬到了芝加哥，开始经营Segunda Vida。
He said, sure, at Segunda Vida they do take the guys' IDs, and they usually keep them in somebody's house. But he said that's for safekeeping. In the past at Segunda Vida, he said, some have been stolen. He confirmed that yes, they have no doctors, no medicine, that when people go through detox, they basically use folk remedies, and he confirmed they are totally unlicensed.
他说，当然，在Segunda Vida他们确实拿走了这些人的身份证，他们通常把它们存放在某人的家里。但他说是为了安全起见。过去在Segunda Vida，他说，有些人被偷了。他证实，是的，他们没有医生，没有药物，当人们排毒时，他们基本上使用民间疗法，他也证实他们完全没有执照。
He said, the government doesn't know we're here. The government doesn't give us any help. And actually, they sound like they're proud of the fact that they're running this group on their own with donations, with their own efforts.
他说，政府不知道我们在这里。政府没有给我们任何帮助。实际上，他们听起来很自豪，因为他们依靠捐款，依靠自己的努力在经营这个小组。
Adriana, did you get any sense of if he was making a lot of money off this?
Adriana，你有没有感觉到他是否靠这个赚了很多钱？
You know, I looked into it, and it didn't really seem like he is a rich guy making tons of money. In fact, yeah, it didn't seem like he was actually benefiting or financially benefiting from this.
你知道，我调查过了，他看起来并不像是一个赚了很多钱的富人。实际上，是的，他看起来并没有从中受益或在经济上受益。
By this point, Adriana had heard about how many of these groups make their money. She'd been told that in Chicago addicts live in these groups for free, with free room and board, for three months. Then after that, they have to pay $50 to $75 a week, which, you know, is cheap, considering that they're getting meals. Efren Moreno confirmed that that's how it works at Segunda Vida.
此时，Adriana已经听说这些小组是如何赚钱的了。她被告知，在芝加哥，瘾君子在这些小组中免费居住，免费提供食宿，为期三个月。之后，他们每周必须支付50到75美元，你知道，考虑到他们有饭吃，这很便宜。Efren Moreno证实了这就是Segunda Vida的运作方式。
The scam-iest thing Adriana had heard about the finances of these groups was that some guys told her that they were taken to get Link cards, which is government assistance for food. And then they'd have to give the cards to the rehab place, which would use them to buy food for everybody who was living there. Moreno told her that he's against that, that he didn't want his participants to get any government assistance, that he wanted them to go out and earn money.
Adriana听到的关于这些小组财务状况最像骗局的事情是，一些家伙告诉她，他们被带去领取Link卡，这是政府提供的食品援助。然后他们必须把卡交给康复所，康复所会用它们给住在那里的人买食物。Moreno告诉她，他反对那样做，他不想让他的参与者得到任何政府援助，他希望他们出去赚钱。
After having this conversation, Adriana wondered if these groups were some kind of evil ripoff of disadvantaged drug users and their families. Moreno told her that these 24-hour groups started in Mexico, and they spread north years ago with a mission that was idealistic.
进行了这次谈话后，Adriana怀疑这些小组是否是某种针对弱势吸毒者及其家庭的邪恶抢劫。Moreno告诉她，这些24小时小组起源于墨西哥，几年前带着理想主义的使命向北传播。
Did talking to him change how you saw the groups?
和他谈话是否改变了你看待这些小组的方式？
Not entirely. It made me realize that he seemed to be someone who wanted to be part of the solution, that he wanted to bring services to those who were not able to get rehab services out there.
不完全是。这让我意识到他似乎是一个想成为解决方案的一部分的人，他想为那些无法在外面获得康复服务的人带来服务。
Like he seemed sincere?
比如他看起来很真诚？
Yeah, that he seemed sincere. But at the same time-- and he even said-- each group has its own rules. And because there is no oversight, it's really hard to know what are those other groups doing.
是的，他看起来很真诚。但与此同时——他甚至说过——每个小组都有自己的规则。而且因为没有监督，真的很难知道那些其他小组在做什么。
Did you ask him about these guys who get sent up from Puerto Rico and then end up out on the street?
你问过他关于那些从波多黎各被送上来最终流落街头的家伙吗？
Yeah, and I also asked the other man that he brought with him.
是的，我也问了他带来的那个人。
And what did they say about that?
他们怎么说？
Basically, they actually do outreach in Puerto Rico to try to get people to come to their place. They actively recruit people from Puerto Rico.
基本上，他们实际上在波多黎各进行外展活动，试图让人们来他们的地方。他们积极在波多黎各招募人员。
The fact that they end up on the street, Efren Moreno told her, that's because they're weak. They don't really want to get clean. By this point, Adriana had figured out about as much as she could in Chicago. It was obvious what she needed to do next.
Efren Moreno告诉她，最终流落街头，那是因为他们软弱。他们并不真正想戒毒。此时，Adriana已经在芝加哥调查得尽可能多了。接下来该做什么显而易见。
I got on a plane.
我上了飞机。
Welcome to San Juan, Puerto Rico, where the local time is 2:50.
欢迎来到波多黎各圣胡安，当地时间是2:50。
So what'd you find out in Puerto Rico?
所以你在波多黎各发现了什么？
Well, I talked to a lot of people. I talked to municipal authorities, local police in different municipalities. I even talked to the governor of Puerto Rico.
嗯，我和很多人谈过。我和市政当局、不同城市的当地警察谈过。我甚至和波多黎各的总督谈过。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. They all say, yes, we do this. They're completely open about sending users off the island.
是的。他们都说，是的，我们这样做。他们对把吸毒者送离岛屿的事情非常坦诚。
Wait. But do they know that these are unlicensed places? Or do they think they're sending people to legitimate rehab facilities?
等等。但他们知道这些是未经许可的地方吗？还是他们认为他们把人送到合法的康复机构？
No, they don't know that these places are unlicensed. They assumed that they're licensed. I don't think they even questioned the fact that they could be unlicensed.
不，他们不知道这些地方没有执照。他们假设它们是有执照的。我想他们甚至没有质疑这些地方可能没有执照的事实。
The list of people who assumed that they were sending people to licensed facilities is long, and it includes four police officers in the municipality of Caguas, the mayor and police commissioner of Juncos, a police officer from Juncos, and another from Utuado, health department officials, and a few people involved in a program called De Vuelta a la Vida, Return to Life.
假设他们把人送到持牌机构的人员名单很长，包括Caguas市的四名警察、Juncos的市长和警察局长、来自Juncos的一名警察，以及另一名来自Utuado的警察、卫生部门官员，还有几个参与了一个名为De Vuelta a la Vida（回归生活）计划的人。
This is the biggest single program involved in flying drug users off the island. It's run by the state police. They help drug addicts get food, clothing, hygiene, and other services on the island. But also, they arrange for lots of them to fly off the island to these unlicensed programs in the United States. And they coordinate the activities of other organizations that do this.
这是参与将吸毒者飞离岛屿的最大单一计划。它由州警察管理。他们帮助瘾君子在岛上获得食物、衣服、卫生用品和其他服务。但同时，他们还安排许多人飞离岛屿到美国这些未经许可的计划中。他们协调其他开展此类活动的组织。
How in the world did you get the governor to talk to you about this subject?
你到底是怎么让总督和你谈论这个问题的？
Yeah, so I was at a local event at a community in Old San Juan. And I noticed that there was a lot of security there. And I didn't know he was going to be there. And I just kind of like-- oh my god, I really have to interview him and ask him about De Vuelta a la Vida.
嗯，我在圣胡安老城的一个社区参加了一个当地活动。我注意到那里有很多安保人员。我不知道他会出现在那里。我只是觉得——天哪，我真的必须采访他并问他关于De Vuelta a la Vida的事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So what's his name?
所以他叫什么名字？
His name is Alejandro Garcia Padilla.
他的名字叫Alejandro Garcia Padilla。
And what'd he say?
他说什么？
So I asked him if he knew about the program De Vuelta a la Vida, the state police program. And he said it was a very successful program, that it was a great opportunity for users in Puerto Rico who were hoping to get off drugs.
所以我问他是否知道州警察计划De Vuelta a la Vida。他说这是一个非常成功的计划，对于波多黎各希望戒毒的吸毒者来说，这是一个绝佳的机会。
Did you tell him that you kept meeting all these addicts from Puerto Rico who ended up in Chicago, and they were supposed to be going to these programs and they basically end up homeless? Did you tell him that?
你告诉他你一直遇到所有这些最终在芝加哥的波多黎各瘾君子吗，他们本应该去这些计划，最后却基本无家可归？你告诉他那个了吗？
Yeah, I explained the situation. But he didn't seem really worried about it. He told me that he knew the mayor of Chicago, Rahm Emanuel, and the governor of Illinois at the time, Pat Quinn, had a lot of services available, and that they, the users, should look for help and try to find services.
是的，我解释了情况。但他看起来并不太担心。他告诉我，他认识芝加哥市长Rahm Emanuel，当时的伊利诺伊州州长Pat Quinn提供了很多服务，他们，即吸毒者，应该寻求帮助并尝试找到服务。
From the state of Illinois.
来自伊利诺伊州。
From the state of Illinois, yes.
来自伊利诺伊州，是的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And if they want to come back here to Puerto Rico, we have services for them, too. They're our brothers. We welcome them.
如果他们想回到波多黎各，我们也有服务给他们。他们是我们的兄弟。我们欢迎他们。
Right. I like his whole attitude is like, well, you know, I'm sure they'll get services. It's going to be fine.
对。我喜欢他整个态度，就像是，好吧，你知道，我相信他们会得到服务的。没问题的。
Yeah. He was pretty much kind of making it sound like, yeah, well, don't worry about it. We got you.
是的。他几乎是让它听起来像，是的，好吧，不用担心。我们有你们。
Adriana also spoke with the woman who runs De Vuelta a la Vida. Her name's Loribi Doval Fernandez. No surprise, even though her organization is helping arrange for drug users from all over the island to fly to treatment in the United States, she said she had no idea she was referring people to unlicensed facilities.
Adriana还与经营De Vuelta a la Vida的女性谈过。她的名字叫Loribi Doval Fernandez。毫无疑问，尽管她的组织正在协助安排岛上各地的吸毒者飞往美国接受治疗，但她说她根本不知道自己把人转诊到了未经许可的设施。
And the interesting thing is that she says it's up to the families of the users to check if these places are certified or licensed or not.
有趣的是，她说是否查看这些地方是否经过认证或许可，取决于用户的家庭。
Even though her agency is sending them to these places?
尽管她的机构把他们送到这些地方？
Well, that's the thing. When I interviewed her, then she was kind of like getting technical and saying, well, we're not referring them. We are pointing them to those places.
嗯，就是这样。当我采访她时，她变得有些技术性，说，嗯，我们不是推荐他们。我们只是把那些地方指给他们看。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We are showing those places to them. Like, we're giving them the information, and it's up to the family or the user himself to check if those places are certified or not.
我们在向他们展示那些地方。就像，我们给了他们信息，而是否检查这些地方是否经过认证取决于家庭或用户自己。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
If they do end up leaving the island under the De Vuelta a la Vida program, they have to sign a liability waiver before they go pretty much saying that no government official is responsible for them once they leave and once they are out of the island.
如果他们确实根据De Vuelta a la Vida计划离开了岛屿，他们必须在走之前签署一份责任豁免书，基本上说，一旦他们离开并且一旦他们不在岛上，任何政府官员都不对他们负责。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The drug users in Chicago told Adriana they never got this message. They said no one told them that they or their families should check out the rehab places before flying to Chicago. Many wouldn't know how to check, she said. They don't have the internet. Some are not in touch with their families. If anything, they said, government officials were reassuring them that everything was going to be really great in Chicago.
芝加哥的吸毒者告诉Adriana他们从未收到这条信息。他们说没有人告诉他们，在飞往芝加哥之前，他们或他们的家人应该去看看这些康复机构。她说，许多人不知道如何去查看。他们没有互联网。有些人没有与家人联系。如果有的话，他们说，政府官员向他们保证，芝加哥的一切都会非常好。
They pretty much trusted the government officials who were sending them here. Like Manuel, he totally trusted that he was coming to a place with all kinds of services.
他们几乎信任那些把他们送到这里的政府官员。就像Manuel，他完全相信他要去一个有各种服务的地方。
In the end, Adriana did find one official who seemed to really understand what was happening with these drug users once they got to the United States. His name is Dr. Angel Gonzalez, and he was with the Puerto Rican Department of Health, Anti-Addiction, and Mental Health Services until last year. About a year ago, while he was still with the agency, he went to a drug treatment conference in Philadelphia, and he heard about the unlicensed places from a reporter there.
最后，Adriana确实找到了一位似乎真正了解这些吸毒者一旦到达美国后发生了什么的官员。他的名字是Angel Gonzalez医生，直到去年他还在波多黎各卫生部抗成瘾和心理健康服务部门工作。大约一年前，当他还在该机构时，他去费城参加了一个药物治疗会议，从那里的一位记者口中听说了这些未经许可的地方。
We felt terrible. I mean, imagine somebody living in these conditions. So we became very alarmed with that.
我们感觉非常糟糕。我是说，想象一下有人生活在这些条件下。所以我们对这件事感到非常惊慌。
He started to alert other officials all over Puerto Rico to the problem. But he says nothing's changed. He told Adriana that the big issue is there are so many injection drug users on the island right now. Puerto Rico's become a big transit point for drugs traveling to the United States from South America. And the budget to treat these users is shrinking.
他开始向波多黎各各地的其他官员通报这个问题。但他说什么都没变。他告诉Adriana，大问题是岛上现在有太多的注射吸毒者。波多黎各已成为毒品从南美前往美国的重大中转站。治疗这些用户的预算正在缩减。
And Dr. Gonzalez says he thinks most of the police or other officials sending users off the island for treatment think, well, it's either this or no treatment at all.
Gonzalez医生说他认为大多数把用户送离岛屿进行治疗的警察或其他官员认为，好吧，总比没有治疗好。
So in other words, it's something's better than nothing.
所以换句话说，有总比没有好。
I guess.
我想是吧。
I guess. Because when you look at somebody like Manuel, he wasn't getting nothing in Puerto Rico. He got HIV meds and methadone. And after Puerto Rico said, not it, and sent him to Segunda Vida, and after he quit Segunda Vita, he tried to sign up for legitimate licensed drug treatment in Chicago, but he ended up on a long waiting list-- kind of a slow motion not it.
我想是吧。因为当你看看像Manuel这样的人时，他在波多黎各什么都没有得到。他得到了艾滋病药物和美沙酮。而在波多黎各宣布“不是我”，并将他送到Segunda Vida之后，在放弃Segunda Vida之后，他试图在芝加哥报名参加合法的持牌药物治疗，但他最终排在了一个长长的等候名单上——这是一种慢动作的“不是我”。
While he's been waiting, he got sick from eating garbage, ended up in the hospital, where they found other physical problems. He got arrested for stealing from a store, did a couple months in jail, where he finally stopped using, Adriana says. Then he got out of jail, and Adriana says he's now using again. He's also found a place to get methadone, and he gets that, too.
当他在等待时，他因吃垃圾生病了，最终住进了医院，在那里他们发现了其他身体问题。他因在商店偷窃被捕，在监狱里关了几个月，在那里他最终停止了吸毒，Adriana说。然后他从监狱出来，Adriana说他又开始吸毒了。他也找到了一个获取美沙酮的地方，他也得到了那个。
He still has no HIV medication. He still doesn't speak English. He still has to put up with the winter. Nine months after he arrived in the United States, Adriana says things seem worse for him-- or in any case, they're certainly no better than they were back in Puerto Rico. Though he does have friends.
他仍然没有艾滋病药物。他仍然不会说英语。他仍然不得不忍受冬天。到达美国九个月后，Adriana说他的情况似乎变得更糟了——或者无论如何，肯定没有比他在波多黎各时好。尽管他确实有朋友。
There's a community of people like him-- addicts that came here with the illusion that they will get great services, and they're now in the streets. And they hang out at the McDonald's. They hang out at the corners. They all hang out all day.
有一个像他这样的人的社区——带着他们会得到很棒服务的错觉来到这里的瘾君子，他们现在流落街头。他们在麦当劳闲逛。他们在角落里闲逛。他们整天都在闲逛。
Because he has those guys, Adriana says, to her surprise, Manuel has stopped trying to get himself back to Puerto Rico.
因为他有那些家伙，Adriana说，令她惊讶的是，Manuel已经停止尝试回波多黎各了。
Coming up, the joke that launched a second joke that launched a third joke that launched a not it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，那个笑话引发了第二个笑话，引发了第三个笑话，引发了一个“不是我”。一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Not It," stories of people passing the buck, saying, not me, shedding responsibility, dropping the hot potato.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“Not It”，人们推卸责任，说，不是我，摆脱责任，丢掉烫手山芋的故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Last But Not Least." This is a story about a city that years ago was given a title and is now saying not it to that title. They do not want the title anymore. Here's Brian Reed.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“最后但并非最不重要”。这是一个关于一个城市的故事，多年前它被赋予了一个称号，现在正对那个称号说“不是我”。他们不再想要那个称号了。这是Brian Reed。
Tim Keown is a junior in high school, and he was sitting in class one day last fall when he learned something about his hometown that shocked him. Tim's lived his whole life in a small city of about 30,000 people-- Kankakee, Illinois. It's about an hour's drive south of Chicago. And so his class was on laptops, researching local Kankakee history together.
Tim Keown是高中二年级学生，去年秋天有一天他坐在教室里时学到了一些关于他家乡的事情，这让他感到震惊。Tim一生都住在一个约3万人的小城市——伊利诺伊州Kankakee。离芝加哥南边大约一小时车程。所以他的班级正在笔记本电脑上一起研究Kankakee的当地历史。
And they showed us this article and it said that, out of 354 cities, that we were ranked the worst city, worst in all the cities in America.
他们给我们看了这篇文章，上面说，在354个城市中，我们被评为最糟糕的城市，美国所有城市中最糟糕的。
Hate to break it to you, Tim, but all the cities in Canada, too. The article was from 1999, the year the ranking came out.
Tim，很遗憾告诉你，加拿大所有的城市也包括在内。这篇文章来自1999年，排名出来的那一年。
It was ridiculous. I couldn't believe it. I grew up thinking our town was fantastic, and then all a sudden I hear, oh yeah, we were ranked the worst city in America. It was pretty hurtful to see that.
这太荒谬了。我简直不敢相信。我从小就认为我们的城镇很棒，然后突然我听说，哦，是的，我们被评为美国最糟糕的城市。看到这个真的很伤人。
The ranking had been published in a book called The Places Rated Almanac . They use nine criteria, like crime, job outlook, climate, and culture, to rate cities' livability. These lists come out all the time. They're a dime a dozen. So people outside of Kankakee probably would have barely noticed it if not for the other thing Tim and his classmates discovered during their research.
该排名发表在一本名为《地方评级年鉴》（The Places Rated Almanac）的书里。他们使用九个标准，如犯罪、就业前景、气候和文化来评价城市的宜居性。这些名单一直都在出来。它们很常见。所以Kankakee外面的人可能几乎不会注意到它，如果不是Tim和他的同学在研究过程中发现的另一件事的话。
The category tonight-- top 10 slogans for Kankakee, Illinois. Here we go. Number 10.
今晚的类别——伊利诺伊州Kankakee的十大标语。我们开始吧。第十名。
In 1999, David Letterman made Kankakee the butt of one of his top 10 lists on the Late Show .
1999年，David Letterman让Kankakee成了他《深夜秀》（Late Show）中十大名单之一的笑柄。
You'll come for a pay phone. You'll stay because your car's been stolen. Number nine. Ask about our staggering unemployment rate. Number eight. We put the ill in Illinois. Number seven. We also put the annoy in Illinois.
你来找公用电话。你会留下来是因为你的车被偷了。第九名。询问我们惊人的失业率。第八名。我们在“Illinois”（伊利诺伊）中放了“ill”（疾病）。第七名。我们还在“Illinois”中放了“annoy”（烦恼）。
My favorite, by the way, number four-- Abe Lincoln slept here by accident. And you know, Kankakee might have even tiptoed past this without attracting too much attention. It was just a short bit. Except that a week and a half later on the Letterman Show , on November 16, 1999.
顺便说一句，我最喜欢的是，第四名——亚伯拉罕·林肯曾在这里睡觉，纯属偶然。你知道，Kankakee甚至可能悄悄地避开这一切而没有引起太多注意。这只是一个小片段。除了一个半星期后在《深夜秀》上，1999年11月16日。
We have the mayor of Kankakee, Donald Green. And we're just going to see how he's doing. He may not be feeling so good, you know.
我们有Kankakee市长Donald Green。我们来看看他怎么样了。他可能感觉不太好，你知道。
Dave called Kankakee's mayor on the phone.
Dave在电话里给Kankakee的市长打了电话。
Kankakee, as you know, finished dead last.
Kankakee，正如你知道的，垫底了。
Right.
对。
Now, how did that make you feel?
那么，这让你有什么感觉？
Well, it sort of hurt. Because that's, in my opinion, not really a true statement of our community.
嗯，有点受伤。因为在我看来，那并不是我们社区的真实陈述。
Mayor, I hate to interrupt you here, but a thought just crossed my mind. Do you think it has anything to do with the name itself?
市长，我很抱歉打断你，但一个想法刚刚闪过我的脑海。你认为这和名字本身有关吗？
No. Kankakee's a fine name.
不。Kankakee是一个好名字。
What is it? Is it an Indian-- is it a Native American name, Kankakee?
它是什么？它是印第安——它是美洲原住民名字吗，Kankakee？
It is an Indian name, right.
它是一个印第安名字，没错。
Do you know what it means?
你知道它是什么意思吗？
It means middle class factory town.
它的意思是中产阶级工厂镇。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Pretty good.
相当不错。
Letterman tells the mayor, I'm going to do you a little favor. He says he feels a connection with Kankakee because he's from Indiana, right next door.
Letterman告诉市长，我要给你一点小恩惠。他说他觉得和Kankakee有联系，因为他来自隔壁的印第安纳州。
So we thought long and hard and we came up with something to give to you to brighten the spirits of you and the community of Kankakee. Do we have it? Turn on the the satellite. Ladies and gentlemen, there it is.
所以我们进行了长时间的认真思考，我们想出了一些东西给你，以照亮你和Kankakee社区的精神。我们有吗？打开卫星。女士们，先生们，就在那儿。
The show cuts to a shot of Kankakee's City Hall, where a trailer is parked out front with some kind of structure sitting on it that's about to be unveiled.
节目切到一个镜头，Kankakee市政厅，前面停着一辆拖车，上面坐着某种结构，正要揭幕。
All right, go ahead. Tell them what it is, Alan.
好了，继续。告诉他们这是什么，Alan。
It's a brand new gazebo! Yes, featuring rugged cedar construction and white-washed to withstand the harsh, inhospitable climate of Kankakee, this gazebo has--
这是一个全新的凉亭！是的，采用坚固的雪松结构和粉刷，以抵御Kankakee严酷、不友好的气候，这个凉亭有——
And if you thought the joke ended there, well, then you did not watch the Late Show two weeks later, December 1, 1999, when Dave called up the mayor of Kankakee yet again while the man was on vacation to tell him he didn't think the show had done quite enough to help the town.
如果你以为笑话到此结束，那么你没有看两周后的《深夜秀》，1999年12月1日，当时Dave再次打电话给Kankakee市长，尽管那个人正在度假，告诉他他不认为节目为帮助这个城镇做了足够的工作。
We have something else, Mr. Mayor. Sit down. Get a hold of yourself.
我们还有别的东西，市长先生。坐下。冷静点。
OK.
好的。
In addition to the gazebo, Alan, tell them what we're giving them.
除了凉亭，Alan，告诉他们我们给他们什么。
Dave, we're giving them another gazebo!
Dave，我们给他们另一个凉亭！
Identical to the first one. Again, the show cuts to downtown Kankakee. Again, there's a gazebo, the second one, sitting on a trailer next to the first with a sign, Letterman's suggestion for a new tourism hook, "Kankakee-- the home of the twin gazebos."
和第一个一模一样。节目再次切到Kankakee市中心。再次，有一个凉亭，第二个，坐在第一个旁边的拖车上，上面有一个标志，Letterman给出的新旅游噱头的建议，“Kankakee——双子凉亭之家”。
(SINGING) There it is. Kankakee's brand new gazebo. It makes everything OK. It's not a placebo. Gazebo. Gazebo.
（唱歌）就在那儿。Kankakee全新的凉亭。它让一切都好了。它不是安慰剂。凉亭。凉亭。
Gazebos were weird for me, because I didn't understand what a gazebo was. Because I hadn't asked my parents about, you know, like, what is this? Why is this here? And then they told me, oh, you know, it was from David Letterman. And that was the end of the story. There was no more talk about it.
凉亭对我来说很奇怪，因为我不明白凉亭是什么。因为我没有问我的父母，你知道，凉亭是什么？为什么它在这里？然后他们告诉我，哦，你知道，它是来自David Letterman的。故事就到此为止了。没有更多关于它的谈话了。
Tim Keown was one when Letterman gave Kankakee the gazebos. So for him growing up, they were just a part of the city that had always been there, like the courthouse or the old root beer stand.
Tim Keown一岁时，Letterman给了Kankakee凉亭。所以对他来说，它们只是城市的一部分，一直都在那里，就像法院或旧根汁汽水摊一样。
It was just, ah, they're from David Letterman. I was like, OK. It was just, there was no talk about it. None of the adults in our community ever really talked about it. They were ashamed of it, I guess.
它只是，啊，它们来自David Letterman。我当时想，好的。它只是，没有关于它的谈话。我们社区里没有任何成年人真正谈论过它。我猜他们为此感到羞耻。
So now 15 years after Letterman gifted the gazebos, as Tim and his classmates were sitting there in school in disbelief, seeing that their hometown had been made into a laughingstock on national television, something clicked for them. Most of the students had lived in Kankakee their entire lives and thought it was fine. And it hit them. You know something? We don't get no respect. We don't get no respect at all. And they'd never understood why.
所以现在在Letterman赠送凉亭15年后，当Tim和他的同学们坐在学校里感到不可思议时，看到他们的家乡在国家电视台上成为了笑柄，他们想通了。大多数学生一生都住在Kankakee，认为它很好。这让他们想通了。你知道吗？我们没有得到尊重。我们根本没有得到任何尊重。他们从来没明白为什么。
We were thought as, like, the lowest of the low because we were from Kankakee.
我们被认为是，像，最底层的，因为我们来自Kankakee。
I visited Tim's class, and the students had so many memories of people from nearby towns sneering at Kankakee.
我参观了Tim的班级，学生们有很多附近城镇的人嘲笑Kankakee的记忆。
What kind of stuff would people say?
人们会说什么样的话？
Rumors and stuff that we were all, like, drug dealers or--
谣言什么的，我们都是毒贩，或者——
The most common was that we were ghetto and everyone was fighting in the hallways.
最常见的是我们是贫民窟，每个人都在走廊里打架。
I transferred to this high school my freshman year, and when I told people where I was transferring they would be like, oh, you're going to Kankakee? Well, good luck.
我高一时转到这所高中的，当我告诉人们我要转到哪里时，他们会说，哦，你要去Kankakee？嗯，祝你好运。
Tim remembers when he was little playing with kids in neighboring towns. Their parents--
Tim记得他小时候和邻镇的孩子们玩。他们的父母——
They wouldn't even want to take me home. I always had to have my parents come pick me up. Like, you don't even want to go over there.
他们甚至不想带我回家。我总是不得不让我父母来接我。就像，你甚至不想去那边。
There was the girl who interviewed to go on an academic exchange program in Spain. She was with students from other schools as she explained that she was on the honor roll, held leadership positions.
有一个女孩面试要去西班牙参加学术交流项目。她和来自其他学校的学生在一起，解释说她在荣誉榜上，担任领导职务。
And as soon as I said, I'm from  Kankakee, this girl turned around and she looked at her friend, and she was like, well, that's not very educational. And I'm like, are they calling me stupid?
一旦我说，我来自Kankakee，这个女孩转过身看着她的朋友，她是这样的，嗯，那不太具有教育意义。我心想，他们是在说我笨吗？
There was the time this student went shopping for a prom tux.
有一次这个学生去买舞会礼服。
Of course they were asking you like, what school are you from? My mom's like, oh, we're from Kankakee. And the girl was like-- she goes to the other girl, you handle them. They're from Kankakee.
当然他们会问你，你是哪个学校的？我妈妈说，哦，我们来自Kankakee。那个女孩是——她对另一个女孩说，你处理他们。他们来自Kankakee。
And of course, there's the nicknames.
当然，还有绰号。
Skankakee is on Urban Dictionary. Skankakee is on Urban Dictionary.
“Skankakee”（贱女人Kankakee）在Urban Dictionary上。Skankakee在Urban Dictionary上。
There are actually several definitions of Kankakee on Urban Dictionary. One, a noun, when a manatee gets a canker sore. But also, quote, "a once thriving railroad town that has become overrun by gangsters and hood rats."
Urban Dictionary上其实有Kankakee的几个定义。一个，名词，当海牛长口疮时。但还有一个，引用，“一个曾经繁荣的铁路小镇，已经变成了被黑帮和混混占据的地方。”
And you can't lay all the blame for that on Letterman. Just like happened to cities across the Midwest, in the early '80s, several huge employers left Kankakee or went under almost overnight, leaving thousands of people out of work. And like also happened to lots of other cities, white people fled Kankakee in droves. Meanwhile, white people stayed in the adjacent suburbs of Bradley and Bourbonnais. As a result, those towns and their joint high school are much whiter than Kankakee, which is about 40% black and 20% Latino. One of the teachers of the class I visited, Steve DiSanto, remembers when he was hired to come to Kankakee High a few years ago.
你不能把责任全推给Letterman。就像发生在中西部各地的城市一样，80年代初，几个大雇主几乎一夜之间离开了Kankakee或倒闭了，成千上万的人失业。也像发生在许多其他城市一样，白人纷纷逃离Kankakee。与此同时，白人留在了相邻的Bradley和Bourbonnais郊区。结果，那些城镇及其联合高中比Kankakee白得多，Kankakee大约有40%是黑人，20%是拉丁裔。我参观的班级的老师之一，Steve DiSanto，记得几年前他被聘请到Kankakee高中时。
I immediately went online, because I didn't know about Kankakee. I discovered quickly a lot of people thought it was bad and poor. There was blogs about it. People would say, oh, it's Skankakee. It's the worst place ever. They make it like it's a jail yard or something.
我立刻上网，因为我不知道Kankakee。我很快发现很多人认为它又坏又穷。有关于它的博客。人们会说，哦，那是Skankakee。那是史上最糟糕的地方。他们把它说得像个监狱院子什么的。
Especially, there's a street here called Hobby. And everyone's like, you can't go out at night. You shouldn't even drive down it. Well, I drove down it when I came here, and what I saw was families. They were black families. So I was like, well, so this must mean something.
特别是有条街叫Hobby。每个人都说，你晚上不能出去。你甚至不应该开车经过它。嗯，我来这里时开车经过了它，我看到的是家庭。那是黑人家庭。所以我心想，嗯，那这一定意味着什么。
I've been out and they're like, I would never go to that side of the town. Well, why? Well, it's dark over there. What do you mean dark? You mean like dark at night? And they're like, no, you know, dark. You know.
我出去了，他们说，我永远不会去城镇的那一边。嗯，为什么？嗯，那边很黑。你是指像晚上那么黑吗？他们会说，不，你知道，黑暗。你知道。
One student said she once overheard a white woman at the Walmart in Bourbonnais going on about a gang banger she claimed to have seen in Kankakee, and how he was probably going to rob her house. As the student was telling me about this, her classmate Darrylneshia chimed in.
一名学生说她曾经在Bourbonnais的沃尔玛听到一位白人女性在谈论她在Kankakee看到的一个黑帮成员，以及他可能会怎么抢劫她的房子。当学生告诉我这件事时，她的同学Darrylneshia插话了。
I have been a lot of places in Kankakee. I've never seen a gang banger. I think what they see is African Americans that are dressed a certain type of way, Mexicans that are dressed a certain type of way. And they're in cliques, so they're like, OK, well, I was told Kankakee is a bad place. Those must be gang bangers.
我在Kankakee去过很多地方。我从来没见过黑帮成员。我认为他们看到的是以某种方式穿着的非洲裔美国人，以某种方式穿着的墨西哥人。他们是帮派，所以他们想，好的，好吧，我被告知Kankakee是个坏地方。那一定是黑帮成员。
So I'm going to go spread this word and say, I've seen gang bangers. No, baby, you've seen a clique of people hanging out just differently than you do. Just like you hang out at Starbucks, they're hanging out at parks and stuff. It doesn't make them gang bangers.
所以我打算去传播这个词说，我见过黑帮成员。不，宝贝，你见过一群人只是和你的穿着方式不同而聚在一起。就像你在星巴克闲逛一样，他们在公园什么的闲逛。这并不让他们成为黑帮成员。
That brings to mind a comment thread I saw on city-data.com titled, "Is Kankakee really dangerous for Caucasians?" in which a woman says she and her husband are looking to purchase a home in Kankakee but, quote, "some of our friends said that area is prominently black and Hispanic and that we would be shot or hurt if we moved into that area because we are white. Is this true?"
这让我想起了我在city-data.com上看到的评论帖，题目是“Kankakee对白人真的危险吗？”其中一位女性说她和丈夫正在考虑在Kankakee买房，但引用，“我们的一些朋友说那个地区主要是黑人和西班牙裔，如果我们因为是白人而搬到那个地区，我们会中枪或受伤。这是真的吗？”
I spent time outside some big stores in the nearby towns, Bradley and Bourbonnais, asking people what they thought of Kankakee. And no one said anything I would call overtly racist-- at least to me standing there with a microphone. In fact, people were pretty low key in their feelings about Kankakee. Some had no problem with the place-- even liked it. And lots talked about it the way people everywhere talk about the part of town they don't go to. They'd heard it was unsafe. They avoided it, but they didn't give it much thought.
我在附近的城镇Bradley和Bourbonnais的大商店外花时间问人们他们怎么看Kankakee。没有人说我认为明显的种族主义的话——至少对我这个站在那里拿着麦克风的人。事实上，人们对Kankakee的感受很低调。有些人对这个地方没问题——甚至喜欢它。很多人谈论它的方式就像人们在各地谈论他们不去的那部分城镇一样。他们听说不安全。他们避开它，但他们没怎么想。
I think that kind of attitude exists all over. Most places have that city or neighborhood that people outside have written off as dangerous or rundown. I think most places have their own Kankakee.
我认为那种态度到处存在。大多数地方都有那个被外面的人注销为危险或破旧的城市或社区。我想大多数地方都有他们自己的Kankakee。
So when the students at Kankakee High finally, after all those years, discovered the true history of their town, they decided enough was enough. Learning that they've been ridiculed on national television as the worst city in America, and then realizing that the symbols of that ridicule, the gazebos, were just sitting there on display in the heart of their city, oh, hell no.
所以当Kankakee高中的学生终于，在这么多年后，发现了他们城镇的真实历史时，他们决定够了。得知他们在国家电视台上被嘲笑为美国最糟糕的城市，然后意识到那些嘲笑的象征，凉亭，就那样陈列在他们城市的中心，噢，见鬼不。
Every time we had to look at them after that point, it was like seeing something that was mocking us.
在那之后，每次我们不得不看它们，就像看到嘲笑我们的东西。
Tim says that was the last straw.
Tim说那是最后一根稻草。
We were all like, why are these still here? It's been 15 years. Why are they even still here? We should get rid of them.
我们都想，为什么这些还在这里？已经15年了。为什么它们还在这里？我们应该处理掉它们。
They found out that they weren't the only ones who felt this way. They saw that Kankakee's economic director had said once in the Chicago Tribune that every year he tries to get the mayor to send the gazebos back to David Letterman, so the students joined that campaign. They met with the mayor and talked her into letting them tear down one of the gazebos. But Tim says just in case outsiders might see them as destructive hooligans--
他们发现不仅仅只有他们有这种感觉。他们看到Kankakee的经济总监曾经在《芝加哥论坛报》上说，每年他都试图让市长把凉亭送回给David Letterman，所以学生们加入了那个运动。他们见了市长，说服她让他们拆除其中一个凉亭。但Tim说，以防万一外人可能认为他们是破坏性的流氓——
We were like, let's try to do it in a funny. Way put it into a rocking chair and send it back to David Letterman. You know, he was retiring, so we thought  it would be funny if he got a rocking chair to go along with it.
我们想，让我们尝试以一种有趣的方式做。把它放进摇椅里送回给David Letterman。你知道，他要退休了，所以我们认为如果他得到一把摇椅配上它会很有趣。
The class contacted David Letterman and persuaded him to receive a rocking chair made of repurposed gazebo wood-- a gift for his retirement, which is happening next month. Almost immediately, there was backlash to the idea. Someone formed a Facebook page with more than 400 likes called Save the Kankakee Gazebos, where people posted angry comments like this one. "Typical of Kankakee to let the gazebos fall into disrepair then tear them down and make a mockery of a very costly gift to the city. This community is just as much a mess as it ever was. How about using their carpentry skills to repair these boarded-up crack houses to make some much-needed, quality low-income housing?"
班级联系了David Letterman并说服他接受一把用改造的凉亭木头制成的摇椅——给他的退休礼物，这将在下个月发生。几乎立即，这个想法受到了反弹。有人成立了一个Facebook页面，有超过400个赞，叫“拯救Kankakee凉亭”，人们在那里发表了愤怒的评论，比如这个。“Kankakee的典型做法是让凉亭陷入失修，然后拆掉它们，对一个对城市来说非常昂贵的礼物进行嘲弄。这个社区和以往一样是一团糟。何不利用他们的木工技能来修理这些被木板封住的裂缝房屋，来制造一些急需的、优质的低收入住房？”
It's true there's more crime in Kankakee than in surrounding areas, including some gangs. There were six murders last year and 100 aggravated assaults in a city of about 30,000 people. And the unemployment rate is still high, almost 10%. But still, the people I talked to who live in Kankakee said they wouldn't want to move. They love it. When I asked them why, they listed the kind of stuff people often feel obliged to say when they answer that kind of question-- the great library, the farmer's market. Though what I'd say I heard the most praise for in Kankakee was its diversity. Standing in front of the class I visited, you could see it, and see that they're proud of it.
确实，Kankakee的犯罪率比周边地区高，包括一些帮派。去年有六起谋杀案，在约3万人的城市里有100起严重袭击。失业率仍然很高，接近10%。但尽管如此，我交谈过的住在Kankakee的人说他们不想搬走。他们爱它。当我问他们为什么时，他们列出了人们在回答那种问题时经常感到有义务说的事情——伟大的图书馆、农贸市场。尽管我会说我在Kankakee听到最多赞美的是它的多样性。站在我参观的班级前面，你可以看到它，并看到他们为它感到自豪。
I am biracial myself, which is a great thing.
我自己是混血儿，这是一件很棒的事情。
This is a student named Alexis.
这是一个叫Alexis的学生。
I am friends with a lot of Mexicans. Muy bien.
我和很多墨西哥人是朋友。非常好。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
And that's not racist because I'm in Spanish 3, so I know Spanish. And I'm friends with white people. This is my best friend. She's white.
而且那不是种族主义，因为我在西班牙语3，所以我懂西班牙语。而且我和白人是朋友。这是我最好的朋友。她是白人。
Can you confirm that?
你能证实吗？
Yep. I'm her best friend.
是的。我是她最好的朋友。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
And that you're white?
而且你是白人？
Oh, yeah. And I'm white, too. I see how it is.
哦，是的。我也是白人。我明白是怎么回事了。
So it's just a really good environment to be in.
所以这是一个非常好的环境。
One student said she transferred to a private school, but she only stayed a few days. She missed the diversity of Kankakee High and having friends around that she could speak Spanish with. It made me wonder. Back in 1999, Kankakee was rated the worst place to live-- for who, exactly?
一名学生说她转到了一所私立学校，但她只待了几天。她错过了Kankakee高中的多样性，错过了有可以用西班牙语交谈的朋友。这让我很纳闷。回到1999年，Kankakee被评为最糟糕的居住地——到底是为谁？
Hello, Kankakee!
你好，Kankakee！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
On a snowy day in February, the students did it. They marched out to the gazebo next to the train station, crowbars and chainsaw in hand, and demolished it. The next month, Letterman sent a crew out to Kankakee to film a new segment for his show, the students presenting him with the rocking chair in front of a live audience at the Paramount, a beautiful old-timey theater downtown. Here's Alexis, the biracial student with the white best friend.
在二月一个下雪的日子里，学生们做到了。他们走到火车站旁边的凉亭，拿着撬棍和链锯，拆毁了它。下个月，Letterman派了一个团队到Kankakee拍摄他节目的新片段，学生们在市中心一个美丽的古老剧院Paramount的现场观众面前向他赠送了摇椅。这是Alexis，那个有白人最好朋友的混血学生。
We welcome you as we show America the greatest hidden treasure in the world, Kankakee. Other schools, employers, and people put us down every day because we live in Kankakee.
我们欢迎你们，当我们向美国展示世界上最伟大的隐藏宝藏，Kankakee时。其他学校、雇主和人们每天都贬低我们，因为我们住在Kankakee。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
This is not right. We should not have to carry this stereotype our whole lives. The time to change is now.
这不对。我们不应该终生背负这种刻板印象。改变的时机就是现在。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
[MARCHING BAND PLAYING]
[行进乐队演奏]
The school marching band filled the aisles, wearing brand new uniforms with red plumes on their hats that arrived just in time for the TV shoot. I know it sounds corny. And sure, there was some corn. But I don't think I've ever been to a high school pep rally where I sensed as much actual pride in the town as I did here.
学校行进乐队挤满了过道，戴着帽子上插着红色羽毛的新制服，赶在电视拍摄前及时送达。我知道这听起来很俗气。当然，也确实有一些俗气。但我不认为我参加过任何一场高中拉拉队集会，在那里我感觉到像在这里一样对城镇的实际自豪感。
[MARCHING BAND PLAYING]
[行进乐队演奏]
Kankakee! Keeko can! Who can? We can! Kankakee can!
Kankakee！Keeko可以！谁可以？我们可以！Kankakee可以！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Kankakee, Keeko can. Who can? We can. Kankakee can. Put that on your top 10 list, Dave.
Kankakee，Keeko可以。谁可以？我们可以。Kankakee可以。把那个放在你的十大名单上，Dave。
[MARCHING BAND PLAYING]
[行进乐队演奏]
Brian Reed is a producer on our program.
Brian Reed是我们节目的制片人。
[MUSIC - STEVIE WONDER "VILLAGE GHETTO LAND"]
[音乐 - Stevie Wonder "Village Ghetto Land"]
Act Three, "The Big Crapple."
第三幕，“大苹果”。（The Big Crapple）
So you've probably heard the acronym NIMBY, short for Not In My Backyard. And can I just say right now, please, Public Radio listeners, do not send me emails telling me how you have always thought that it should be NIMB because "backyard" is one word. I'm tired of hearing it. So just keep that thought to yourself.
所以你们可能听说过首字母缩略词NIMBY，Not In My Backyard（别在我的后院）。我能现在就说吗，请公共广播听众，不要发电子邮件告诉我你是如何一直认为它应该是NIMB的，因为“backyard”是一个词。我厌倦了听到它。所以把那个想法留在心里吧。
Anyway, NIMBY is a community-- I think you know this-- yelling, we don't want your nuclear power plant or your prison or your whatever. Anyway, Zoe Chace has this story of perhaps misplaced NIMBY-ism.
总之，NIMBY是一个社区——我想你知道这个——大喊，我们不想要你的核电站或监狱或无论什么。总之，Zoe Chace有这个或许错位的NIMBY主义的故事。
A few months ago, I was going to a party with my friends. And we were getting ready together. And while we were putting on our dresses, I started doing this thing that I do a lot, which is comparing. Like, how do you put on your eyeliner so well, and that's such a nice bracelet that you're wearing.
几个月前，我要去参加朋友的聚会。我们正在一起准备。当我们穿裙子时，我开始做我经常做的事情，那就是比较。就像，你的眼线怎么画得那么好，你戴的那条手链真好看。
And then I noticed, dude, you're armpits are so smooth. Like, that is what I want. How do you get them so perfectly hairless? And she was like, I laser. I laser off the hairs. My mind was blown, like, yeah, this is expensive upfront, but cheaper in the long run because the hair doesn't come back. And it looked so nice.
然后我注意到，伙计，你的腋下太光滑了。就像，那是我想要的。你是怎么让它们变得那么完美无毛的？她说，我用激光。我用激光去除毛发。我的大脑被震住了，就像，是的，这前期昂贵，但从长远来看更便宜，因为毛发不会再长出来。而且看起来太好了。
Sometimes I hear about the way somebody solves a problem, and I cannot get it out of my head. Like, why don't I do it that way? That just seems better. This is how I felt when I learned about the way they deal with garbage in Europe.
有时我听说别人解决问题的方式，我无法把它赶出脑海。比如，为什么我不那样做？那看起来更好。当我了解到他们处理欧洲垃圾的方式时，我就是这种感觉。
Compared to the United States, Europe-- well, Northern Europe-- seemed like a garbage utopia to me when I first heard about it. There are all these fancy incinerators. And they're incredibly efficient. They barely pollute. Like, the amount of hazardous chemicals that come out of these things is equivalent to a fireplace.
与美国相比，欧洲——嗯，北欧——当我第一次听说它时，看起来像是一个垃圾乌托邦。有这么多昂贵的焚烧炉。而且效率极高。它们几乎不污染。比如，从这些东西中出来的危险化学物质的数量相当于一个壁炉。
And on top of that, some of them are really pretty. This one in Denmark looks like a gay club with twinkly lights. This one in France is all covered with grass. And the whole point is they convert garbage into energy. They produce steam, which heats their homes and businesses.
最重要的是，其中一些非常漂亮。丹麦的这一个看起来像一个带有闪烁灯光的同性恋俱乐部。法国的这一个被草覆盖。整个重点是它们将垃圾转化为能源。它们产生蒸汽，为他们的家庭和企业供暖。
We do not do this in the United States. We do not have these super efficient, beautiful garbage-to-energy incinerators, not that many of them, anyway. More than half of our garbage goes to landfills. And as you know, landfills are pretty much the worst. They release methane 20 times more powerful than carbon dioxide. To be fair, incinerators also pollute. They produce carbon dioxide and ash, just a lot less pollution than landfills. Germany, Austria, Sweden, the Netherlands, Denmark, they landfill almost nothing. They recycle around half their waste. And they burn the rest of their garbage in these things that generate electricity and heat.
我们不在美国这样做。我们没有这些超高效、美丽的垃圾发电焚烧炉，至少没有那么多。我们一半以上的垃圾去了垃圾填埋场。而且如你所知，垃圾填埋场基本上是最糟糕的。它们释放的甲烷比二氧化碳强20倍。公平地说，焚烧炉也会污染。它们产生二氧化碳和灰烬，只是比垃圾填埋场的污染少得多。德国、奥地利、瑞典、荷兰、丹麦，它们几乎不填埋任何东西。它们循环利用大约一半的废物。然后它们把剩下的垃圾烧掉，生成电力和热量。
All right, so when I heard about this, I wondered, why do the Europeans have so many and we have so few? And the answer really boils down to this is not Europe. This is a big country. We have a lot of land. Landfilling is just so much cheaper here. And that was the answer to my question. Except there are a lot of places in the United States where there is not a lot of space, where land is super expensive, like New York City, where I live.
好的，当我听说这个时，我想，为什么欧洲人有这么多而我们这么少？答案真的归结为这不是欧洲。这是一个大国家。我们有很多土地。填埋在这里便宜得多。这就是我问题的答案。除了美国有很多地方没有多少空间，土地超贵，比如我居住的纽约市。
New York doesn't deal with any of its garbage itself. 80% goes to a landfill somewhere else. Trucks get on I-78 and drive hundreds of miles to Eastern Ohio to drop off my Chinese takeout containers. Sending our trash away costs $300 million a year. That's just for the transportation. New York kind of seems like the perfect place for a fancy new waste-to-energy incinerator. So why don't we have one here?
纽约市自己不处理任何垃圾。80%去了别处的垃圾填埋场。卡车开上I-78公路，开几百英里到俄亥俄州东部，扔掉我的中餐外卖盒。运送我们的垃圾一年要花3亿美元。这只是交通费。纽约看起来简直是 fancy 新垃圾能源焚烧炉的完美地方。所以为什么我们这里没有？
This actually comes up all the time in New York. It's been debated over and over. And it never happens. And I know exactly why.
这实际上在纽约一直出现。它被争论过一遍又一遍。而且永远不会发生。而且我确切知道为什么。
So let's go back to pretty much the very first time a waste-to-energy incinerator was proposed, 1980s New York City. Back then, New York was stuffing all its trash into these towering landfills all over the city. Norman Steisel was the commissioner of New York City sanitation, and he remembers.
所以让我们回到几乎第一次提议垃圾能源焚烧炉的时候，1980年代的纽约市。那时，纽约把所有垃圾塞进全市高耸的垃圾填埋场。Norman Steisel是纽约市环卫局局长，他记得。
The trucks literally could not climb the hill. It was basically such a sharp peak that they couldn't get to the top to dispose any of the waste.
卡车字面上无法爬上山。它基本上是一个如此尖锐的顶峰，以至于它们无法到达顶部来处理任何废物。
So they were driving up, basically, a volcano in the Bronx that was built on garbage.
所以他们基本上是在开一辆建立在垃圾上的布朗克斯火山。
Right it's all built out of garbage and dirt. And there were these vast underground fires, which took literally years to put out and get under control.
对，它全部由垃圾和泥土建成。而且有这些巨大的地下火灾，字面上花了好几年才扑灭并得到控制。
Not only were they scary, the landfills were almost full. So Steisel and the Koch administration decided to put these waste-to-energy incinerators, like the ones they had in Europe then-- one in every borough, the Bronx, Queens, Brooklyn, Manhattan, Staten Island.
不仅它们很可怕，垃圾填埋场也几乎满了。所以Steisel和Koch行政部门决定把这些垃圾能源焚烧炉，就像欧洲那时拥有的那些——每个区一个，布朗克斯、皇后区、布鲁克林、曼哈顿、史泰登岛。
But the problem in New York City is everywhere you go, someone is there, someone to say not it. In this case, the first incinerator would be built in the Brooklyn Navy Yard right near a community of Hasidic Jews. Like I said, any community in New York would have come up with a reason they should be not it. And the Hasids told Steisel one of theirs.
但纽约市的问题是无论你去哪里，都有人在那里，有人说“不是我”。在这种情况下，第一个焚烧炉将在布鲁克林海军造船厂建造，靠近一个哈西德派犹太人社区。像我说的，纽约的任何社区都会想出一个理由说明他们应该是“不是我”。哈西德派告诉Steisel他们其中一个。
The waste-to-energy incinerator would remind them of the Holocaust experiences. And when I tried to explain to them that, as a son of a Holocaust survivor myself, I thought they were demeaning that whole experience. And there was one rabbi in particular who accused me rather publicly of being the young Dr. Mengele, experimenting with the lives of Jewish women and children.
垃圾能源焚烧炉会让他们想起大屠杀经历。当我试图向他们解释，作为大屠杀幸存者的儿子，我认为他们是在贬低整个经历。有一个拉比特别公开指责我是年轻的门格勒医生（Dr. Mengele），在犹太妇女和儿童的生活上做实验。
Lots of people, for many reasons, did not trust the Steisel-Koch plan in New York. No neighborhood would take them.
很多人，由于很多原因，不信任纽约的Steisel-Koch计划。没有社区会接受它们。
But the plan lingered. The mayor still wanted to do this seemingly logical, energy generating, less polluting thing for New York City. But what sealed the fate of the New York incinerator was when New York's garbage became an international incident.
但计划挥之不去。市长仍然想为纽约市做这种看似合乎逻辑的、产生能源的、污染较少的事情。但最终决定纽约焚烧炉命运的是纽约的垃圾成为了一次国际事件时。
This is the continuing saga of a homeless garbage barge. 3,000 tons of New York garbage floating from port to port, looking for a place to be dumped.
这是流浪垃圾驳船的持续传奇。3000吨纽约垃圾从港口漂流到港口，寻找被倾倒的地方。
Here's Tom Brokaw in 1987. For weeks, night after night, he reported on the wandering Mobro garbage barge. You might have heard about this. It was a really big deal.
这是1987年的Tom Brokaw。几周来，夜复一夜，他报道了漫游的Mobro垃圾驳船。你们可能听说过。那是一件大事。
Here's what happened. A landfill in Long Island was full. A guy out there cut a deal to send it to North Carolina. Ship the garbage on a barge down south, and they'll put it in their landfill. Except once it got to North Carolina, someone said they saw a bedpan on the barge, medical waste. And they wouldn't take it.
这是发生的事情。长岛的一个垃圾填埋场满了。那边的一个家伙达成了一个协议把它送到北卡罗来纳州。把垃圾用驳船运到南边，他们会把它放进他们的垃圾填埋场。除了它一旦到了北卡罗来纳州，有人说他们在驳船上看到了一个便盆，医疗废物。而且他们不会接受。
So the garbage barge set off on this journey of rejection. Alabama, nope. Louisiana--
所以垃圾驳船踏上了这次拒绝之旅。阿拉巴马州，不。路易斯安那州——
While I would like to help them, we just don't have room for it. And we do not intend to allow them to bring it into Louisiana.
虽然我想帮助他们，但我们就是没有空间。而且我们不打算允许他们把它带进路易斯安那州。
The barge tried to go to Mexico. But the Mexican Navy came out into the Gulf and fought them off.
驳船试图去墨西哥。但墨西哥海军开到海湾把它们打退了。
Speaking of geography, the tiny, poor Central American nation of Belize, well, it too says no to the garbage.
说到地理，微小的、贫穷的中美洲国家伯利兹，嗯，它也对垃圾说不。
The barge led the world news at night. It led Johnny Carson .
驳船在晚上的世界新闻上领先。它在Johnny Carson秀上领先。
Take your barge up into the Gulf of Persia. And there is Iran. Dump it right there.
把你的驳船带到波斯湾。那里是伊朗。把它倒在那里。
Florida? Nope. The Bahamas, no. The barge was a tragic figure, a pariah. It went more than 5,000 miles back and forth in the ocean. And with nowhere to go, it finally returned to New York.
佛罗里达州？不。巴哈马群岛，不。驳船是一个悲剧人物，一个贱民。它在海洋中来回航行了超过5000英里。由于无处可去，它最终回到了纽约。
There were court battles around what to do with it. And environmentalists seized upon this moment. Eventually, the city figured out it was mostly paper and cardboard. And a bunch of Greenpeace people hung this banner across the garbage, saying, next time, try recycling.
围绕着该怎么处理它有法庭诉讼。环保主义者抓住了这一刻。最终，城市发现它主要是纸和纸板。一群绿色和平组织的人把这个横幅挂在垃圾上，写着，下次，尝试循环利用。
You might have thought with all this anxiety about garbage and what to do with it, this would be the moment for European-style waste-to-energy incinerators to take off. But it turns out, the biggest opponent of waste-to-energy incinerators is the recyclers. Yeah, the recyclers.
你可能以为有了所有这些对垃圾和该怎么处理它的焦虑，这将是欧洲式垃圾能源焚烧炉起飞的时刻。但事实证明，垃圾能源焚烧炉最大的反对者是循环利用商。是的，循环利用商。
We believe that Americans don't want to burn their trash. They'd rather recycle it. And they'd rather produce less of it because they realize that there's a cost to trash.
我们相信美国人不想烧掉他们的垃圾。他们宁愿循环利用它。而且他们宁愿少产生它，因为他们意识到垃圾是有成本的。
This is Eric Goldstein, avid recycler in New York City. He's been with the National Resource Defense Council for more than 30 years. He is resolute against incinerators. He thinks that incinerators actually discourage recycling. They compete for the same stuff. And less recycling, that's worse for the environment. If you don't recycle, he says, then it's like you have to use natural resources to make a new thing every time. It's better to use the plastic from a plastic bottle as much as you possibly can, rather than drill for more oil in order to make brand new ones.
这是Eric Goldstein，纽约市的热心循环利用商。他在自然资源保护委员会已经工作了30多年。他坚定地反对焚烧炉。他认为焚烧炉实际上阻碍了循环利用。它们争夺同样的东西。循环利用减少，那对环境更糟糕。如果你不循环利用，他说，那么就像你每次必须使用自然资源来制造新东西一样。尽可能多地使用塑料瓶里的塑料，而不是钻探更多的石油来制造全新的，这更好。
But it seemed weird to me that you'd have to choose. Like in Germany, they recycle more than 60% of their garbage and incinerate almost 40%. We went back and forth about this a lot.
但对我来说，必须做出选择看起来很奇怪。就像在德国，他们循环利用60%以上的垃圾，焚烧近40%。我们关于这个来回争论了很多。
In Germany, they do both. They do both.
在德国，他们两者都做。他们两者都做。
But that doesn't make it right.
但这并不意味着它是对的。
But it's better.
但这更好。
It would be better if Germany were to recycle more and compost more and reuse more and generate less waste.
如果德国能更多地循环利用、更多地堆肥、更多地重复使用并产生更少的废物，那会更好。
But they're recycling so much more than we do.
但他们循环利用的比我们多得多。
So that's why we need to focus on recycling.
所以这就是为什么我们需要专注于循环利用。
But then why do we have to not burn trash while we focus on recycling?
但那么为什么我们必须在专注于循环利用的同时不烧垃圾？
City officials only have so much time, energy, and resources to transform waste policy so that it places recycling and prevention and composting as the cornerstones. Requires a lot of work. It's not going to be easy. And it's probably going to take another decade or so before that transformation is complete in places like New York City.
城市官员只有有限的时间、精力和资源来改变废物政策，使其将循环利用、预防和堆肥作为基石。需要大量工作。那不会容易。而且这种转变在像纽约市这样的地方完成可能还需要十年左右的时间。
While that's going on, he says, we can't let officials be distracted by incinerators. This has been the philosophy that rules New York to this day, focus on recycling.
虽然正在进行中，他说，我们不能让官员被焚烧炉分心。这就是直到今天统治纽约的哲学，专注于循环利用。
The latest attempt at getting a European-style waste-to-energy facility in New York happened three years ago in 2012 under Mayor Bloomberg. And it did not go well. At the time, James Oddo was a councilman on Staten Island. And he remembers being at an event when a city government guy approached him. And he said this.
在纽约获得欧洲式垃圾能源设施的最新尝试发生在三年前的2012年，在彭博市长任内。而且进行得并不好。那时，James Oddo是史泰登岛的市议员。他记得在一次活动中，一个市政府人员接近他。他说这个。
Just keep an open mind. Don't fly off the handle.
保持开放的心态。别反应过度。
The guy knew the issue might be sensitive because when it comes to garbage, Staten Island has lost New York City's not it game for decades.
那个人知道这个问题可能很敏感，因为说到垃圾，史泰登岛在几十年里一直输给纽约市的“不是我”游戏。
In 1948, Robert Moses built a landfill on Staten Island. Fresh Kills, it's old Dutch. Means "fresh stream." At the time, he promised it would only be around for three years. 50 years later, it's one of the biggest landfills in the world.
1948年，Robert Moses在史泰登岛建了一个垃圾填埋场。Fresh Kills，是古荷兰语。意思是“新鲜的溪流”。那时，他承诺它只会存在三年。50年后，它是世界上最大的垃圾填埋场之一。
When you were a kid and you went to the Staten Island Mall on a hot summer day, you used to take a deep breath in the car and get out of the car and run to the mall because you didn't want to deal with the smell. This history for native Staten Islanders is something that we never forgive. And anytime an issue having to do with solid waste arises, Staten Island elected officials get their back-up.
当你还是个孩子，在炎热的夏日去史泰登岛购物中心时，你过去在车里深呼吸，下车跑到购物中心，因为你不想处理那种气味。这种历史对史泰登岛本地人来说是我们永远不会原谅的事情。而且任何与固体废物有关的问题出现时，史泰登岛民选官员就会退缩。
So in 2012, the Bloomberg people called Staten Island to talk about this great new technology for dealing with waste. We're exploring lots of different places to put this facility, they said. Except when the city put out the official document calling for bids, they had only one suggestion for where to build it, Staten Island, on top of the Fresh Kills Landfill. James Oddo predictably flipped out. He said, no.
所以在2012年，彭博团队给史泰登岛打电话谈论这种处理废物的新技术。我们正在探索很多不同的地方来放置这个设施，他们说。除了当城市发布正式文件呼吁投标时，他们只有一个建造建议，史泰登岛，在Fresh Kills垃圾填埋场之上。James Oddo不出所料地翻脸了。他说，不。
Now, our dance card was filled. And now it was time for some other boroughs to run point on this new technology. It wasn't going to be Staten Island.
现在，我们的舞卡填满了。现在是其他区为这项新技术运行的时候了。它不会是史泰登岛。
Manhattan, 42nd Street.
曼哈顿，42街。
Times Square.
时代广场。
Times Square. I want it right there on Times Square, where all the tourists are, where all the attractions are. Let it go in a place like that.
时代广场。我要它就在那里，在时代广场，游客所在的地方，景点所在的地方。让它去像那样的地方。
This is Beryl Thurman. She works on environmental justice issues. And she lives on Staten Island.
这是Beryl Thurman。她从事环境正义问题工作。而且她住在史泰登岛。
Staten Island doesn't trust the City of New York in anything that has to do with garbage.
史泰登岛不信任纽约市任何与垃圾有关的事情。
Even knowing all this, the Bloomberg administration moved ahead with their plan. In April 2012, they got in touch with the people who had bid on the proposal and organized a bus tour out to Fresh Kills to look at the proposed site.
即使知道这一切，彭博政府仍推进了他们的计划。2012年4月，他们联系了投标提案的人，并组织了一次去Fresh Kills查看提议地点的巴士之旅。
Only something very weird happened right at the time the bus was supposed to show up. A nearby compost plant, which was mostly wood chips caught on fire. And it was actually a major fire. There was smoke blowing up over the interstate. You could see it from Manhattan. The bus tour was canceled. The smoke reminded Staten Island of what burning garbage might mean for them.
只有非常奇怪的事情发生在巴士本应出现的时候。一个附近的堆肥厂，主要是木屑着火了。而且它实际上是一场大火。烟雾吹到州际公路上。你可以从曼哈顿看到它。巴士之旅取消了。烟雾让史泰登岛想起了燃烧垃圾对他们意味着什么。
And the next day, when Bloomberg went out to thank the firefighters, he got an earful from the Staten Island politicians infuriated about the waste-to-energy proposal on Staten Island. In an hour-and-a-half after he left, Bloomberg's deputy mayor pulled the deal. No incinerator or gasification or heat turning trash into energy European-style nothing. Not in New York, where someone is always not it. And while I was researching this story, someone raised the point that the compost fire was awfully well timed. I asked Beryl about this.
第二天，当彭博出去感谢消防员时，他从愤怒的史泰登岛政客那里听到了关于史泰登岛垃圾能源提案的抱怨。他离开后的一个半小时里，彭博的副市长取消了这笔交易。没有焚烧炉或气化或将垃圾变成能源的欧洲风格的什么东西。不在纽约，有人总是“不是我”。而且当我在调查这个故事时，有人提出了堆肥火灾的时机好得令人怀疑。我问Beryl关于这个。
Were there conspiracy theories about who started the fire?
有关于谁放火的阴谋论吗？
Well, you know, it was-- you always have that in the back of your mind. But you know.
嗯，你知道，它是——你总是把那个放在脑后。但你知道。
It was fortuitous.
它是幸运的。
It was, wasn't it? Wasn't that amazing how that worked out? What?
它是，不是吗？那竟然是那么令人惊奇的运作方式？什么？
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
Are you saying what it sounds like you're saying?
你是说它听起来像你说的那样吗？
I am not saying anything, other than it was really kind of ironic. It's just one of those coincidences.
我什么都没说，除了它真的很讽刺。这只是巧合之一。
The official word from the fire department said the wood chips set themselves ablaze. I guess that happens.
消防局的正式说法说木屑自己着火了。我想那会发生。
Fresh Kills is closed. New York City's landfills are full. Now the plan is for New York to incinerate a lot more of its garbage, more than a third. But the catch is not in New York. New York will pay to haul our garbage to places like Niagara Falls and Delaware Valley to waste-to-energy incinerators that were built there 20 years ago. So those places will get the benefits-- some electricity and some heat from my Chinese takeout container. And you're welcome. Because New York certainly does not want that here.
Fresh Kills关闭了。纽约市的垃圾填埋场满了。现在计划是纽约焚烧更多垃圾，超过三分之一。但问题是，不在纽约。纽约将付钱把我们的垃圾运到像尼亚加拉大瀑布和特拉华河谷那样的地方，运到20年前建的垃圾能源焚烧炉。所以那些地方会得到好处——一些电力和一些来自我的中餐外卖盒的热量。而且不客气。因为纽约绝对不想那个在这里。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program.
Zoe Chace是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "DON'T THROW YOUR LOVE IN THE GARBAGE CAN" BY VICKI ANDERSON]
[音乐 - Vicki Anderson "Don't Throw Your Love in the Garbage Can"]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell. Production help from Simon Adler.
我们的节目由Brian Reed制作，Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, 和 Nancy Updike合作。我们的高级制片人是Julie Snyder。Joel Lovell提供了编辑帮助。Simon Adler提供了制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Grey and from Rob Geddis.
Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的办公室经理。Elna Baker为我们的节目寻找故事。今天的研究帮助来自Michelle Harris和Christopher Swetala。音乐帮助来自Damien Grey和Rob Geddis。
Adriana Cardona-Maguigad did a lot of our investigation into Puerto Rican drug addicts as a fellow with the Social Justice News Nexus at Northwestern University. She went to Puerto Rico with support from the Fund for Investigative Journalism. Bill Healy, Kari Lyderson, and the Center for Investigative Journalism in Puerto Rico helped with reporting.
Adriana Cardona-Maguigad作为西北大学社会正义新闻Nexus的研究员，完成了我们对波多黎各瘾君子的大量调查。她在调查新闻基金的支持下去了波多黎各。Bill Healy, Kari Lyderson，和波多黎各调查新闻中心帮助了报道。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always today to our program's co-founder, Mr. Tory Malatia. He's doing this new thing where whenever he walks out of a room, he says, hasta la vista, baby. And then he turns and says--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心发送到公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Tory Malatia先生。他在做这个新事情，每当他走出房间时，他说，hasta la vista, baby（再见，宝贝）。然后他转身说——
That's not racist because I'm in Spanish 3, so I know Spanish.
那不是种族主义，因为我在西班牙语3，所以我懂西班牙语。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "DON'T THROW YOUR LOVE IN THE GARBAGE CAN" BY VICKI ANDERSON]
[音乐 - Vicki Anderson "Don't Throw Your Love in the Garbage Can"]